So we had our panel discussion on the stifling of free speech and university
campuses November 11 with doctor sad and doctor Mfa and it was a capacity crowd,
1500 it was sold out and there was people that came from all over Canada and the
u s even some people from Europe.
Surprisingly.
And I guess you and I chatted about this before that I was really surprised at
the absolute lack of any mainstream media coverage of an issue that is very
important for our times and the fact that it was the largest such event held in
Canada.
So I'm surprised about it,
but you didn't seem so surprised about it.
Why is that?
Well,
but not really surprised,
I would say at the moment by anything that happens,
let's say in that conventional media.
Um,
I think that what's happened to large degree is that the people,
the journalists who operate in that sphere have started confusing themselves
with the newsmakers themselves.
And so they feel in some sense like they should be leading the narrative,
let's say instead of saying we get,
and so if an event occurs,
that's outside of what they assume.
I mean,
we're painting this with a broad brush because there's obviously journalists who
don't fit into this category.
Um,
but if it doesn't fall under their
fall under the guidelines of their a priori story,
then it isn't news.
And all that's happening as a consequence of that though,
I think Serena,
is that they're the mainstream media,
so to speak,
is dooming itself to irrelevancy at an unbelievably rapid rate.
See that with,
uh,
certainly,
um,
American news newspapers,
which are now being replaced because people are tuning into social media to get
their news.
Uh,
and a lot of people say they don't even actually trust mainstream journalists
anymore,
which is a sad statement because media is such an important aspect of any
democratic society.
Yeah.
Well,
it's become democratized in a big way.
And so maybe this is for the best,
it's hard to say.
Um,
there'll be pros and cons.
I mean,
I've had,
I can't complain about my treatment at the hands of the media over the last year
in general,
though,
I mean,
there's been a lot of like post media,
the entire post media group of about 250 newspapers came out in support of what
I was doing and Margaret went to and Christie Blatchford and Conrad Black and
are two,
so em to Nela and a whole array of,
of journalists have been very forceful advocates,
I would say for free speech.
So we also want to keep that in mind,
right?
Absolutely.